this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's taking a look at even
more of the varied guns from hot dogs
four shoes and hand grenades setting
aside the um
graphic murderer of a hot dog with
bullet and bayonets what we've got here
is clearly not a real gun
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to video game firearms make
sure to hit that subscribe button and if
there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
if you'd like to help out the royal
armouries and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan oh
goodness
okay paul's there once again we see the
spas 12 semi-automatic slash pump action
shotgun and another thing that excites
me a bit about vr
is the ability to aim like you would aim
a
an actual firearm what's great about
potential for vr
is that you can actually line up the
front and the rear sign so you're lining
up the
target with the front sight with the
rear sight with your virtual eyeball
that's exactly how you aim a gun sounds
obvious but um something that you don't
get to do in most
games so that's that's where something
like this that focuses on the
realism of the manipulations and the
spas looks pretty
pretty well done you've got a stock you
can unfold and you'd want to
if you're trying to actually aim with it
the loading was the only thing that
raised an eyebrow
because it kind of looked like a like a
transparent pez dispenser or something
but i i'm guessing that's a limitation
of how you how you manipulate things in
vr
it looked like you can pick up a single
cartridge and load that but
the standard load is almost like just a
pacman eating pills
pushing the cartridges into the loading
port
you can't argue with a bit of dual wield
pistols
why not well in reality why not is
because you'd miss
quite enjoying the the physics of
preston magazine catch the magazine
drops out
where you can actually see what's going
on it's not just a canned reloading
animation
so this is a glock glock 17 by the look
of it and then
we then pick up the monstrosity with one
of these
aftermarket butt stocks on it and a drum
magazine
and a red dot sign again not something
you'd use in real life
because it turns a compact potentially
conceivable
useful self-defense weapon into none of
those things
uh so we've got a smith and wesson i
think it's a
model 686 so just like the single action
we see a really good
depiction of how double action works
double action is what this is and what
the the revolver you've
just seen in the game is you can either
fire it with the action of pulling
through on the trigger i'll just do it
once on this one
or by cocking the hammer and firing it
which is more accurate less disturbance
of aim that's double action but because
the
single action trigger cocking guns just
disappeared
the meaning changed and now it means a
gun that the
um performs a single action of cocking
um or the double action of cocking and
firing
and that's that's depicted really well
and we actually see the player
experimenting with the trigger so he's
kind of part pulling the hammer back
seeing the hammer move back and then
forward again and the hat the uh
cylinder is being part revolved so in
other words just like
all of these other vr guns they're
working like the real thing
we also see the reload swing out
cylinders on both of these models of
smith and wesson
press the latch open the cylinder and
see the player trying to encourage the
empties out but
um when brass is fired or stealing cases
even
they do expand slightly and they tend to
stay where they are you need something
to knock them out what we then see the
player do is hammer on the ejector
and sure enough the empties come flying
out just like the real thing
huh
setting aside the um graphic murderer of
a hot dog
with bullet and bayonet what we've got
here is clearly not a real gun
i gather it's called the kalashna luger
and uh it's a highly improbable meld
of an ak front end and
a fully automatic luger that has a
shoulder stop designed into the back of
it
what can i say other than why i don't
think it would work
here's the other thing i suppose i would
say what you'd have to do is mount the
ak
front end on some sort of bracket
to the frame of the louver and then just
have the
barrel floating in thin air a line
such that the bullet goes through the ak
ball
because luger's work like other
self-loading pistols
many other self-loading pistols where
the barrel actually recoils slightly so
if you weld an ak barrel to the front of
the luger barrel
it isn't going to work
ar-15s they're everywhere they've
clearly
incorporated a good amount of modularity
into this
version so you can change out different
different parts of it
it looks to function quite realistically
with the suppressor including lots of
gas coming out of the what i took to be
the
ejection port the reloading was was good
i like the uh
the um pretty successful john wick flick
there ejecting the empty magazine out to
the side and
in with a dramatic flourish i'm not sure
about the
skeet shooting with loaded magazines
that would be ill-advised to try in
reality
that's another first for me in video
games probably wrong about this but um i
certainly don't remember seeing
adjustable sites where you can
lock onto the slider and change the
actual setting of the sites
it's just it's not something that's
normally done it's too detailed for a
typical
mainstream game so we saw that on the um
the stronger there some really good
manipulations there with of
so the crocking handle works as it were
to the ejection port pops open as it
comes back and we saw some some good
uh footage there of a cartridge being
extracted back out of the chamber and
going in
and if you cycle manually the live
cartridge flies out of the gun again
it's not something you can do in your
typical 2d game
clause there the bren gun is an iconic
like british light machine gun except of
course it's a check design
i like the the use of the bipod the
ability to
rest that on a surface and use the bipod
rather than
either no bipod or a press-x to mount
gun system where it just kind of
magically magnetic magnetizes to a
nearby surface and you use it that way
here because of the ability to move
things around in virtual space
you can literally plunk it on a wall and
shoot
the reloads a little hard to judge
because i can't see the hands
i'm not sure what's being sort of
actuated to release the magazine
in real life what the the gunners were
taught to do is
reach up with the heel of the hand hit
the magazine catch and
sweep the magazine out of the magazine
well in one smooth motion
lots of debates about brain guns and
mg42s in
the second world war but in reality the
effective rate of fire if you're using
the guns
as they were intended to be used and
could safely
be used without wearing them out was
about the same about 200 rounds
per minute even though the cyclic rate
was 600
approximately for the brand which is
pretty much what you see here so it's
this is clearly a very unreal situation
that we're seeing the guns in
but within those limitations we're
seeing a lot of realism in how the guns
are depicted
pausing there we've covered the the
henry rifle
in a previous video the game benefits
from the inclusion of this
in particular because of the unusual
loading system with the
tube magazine under the barrel but
you're loading it from the front and
then you drop the rounds down the tube
so far so correct
where it goes a bit weird is the sort of
unit of the multiples of ammunition
you're putting in
because they they kind of magic their
way into the feed sometimes not all the
models seem to do it this way but
some of them are sort of you're bringing
the feed source to the gun
the gun is getting loaded but they're
not physically going in in the way that
they would in real life and so what we
see is
the cartridge is going in bullet first
which wouldn't
wouldn't go well you'd instantly jam as
you cycle the action
the first round that the weapon
encounters is
backwards
pause there that's a really nice parrot
i like that
i i think that the thing i noticed the
most is the sound effects
of shooting at long distance with a very
powerful cartridge
where you've got sound echoing off the
hillside
the way it's the way it's modelled it
looks spot on the barrel
it's a short recoil gun so the barrel is
is moving
backward a short distance the only thing
holding you back in real life
is upper body strength really because
firing it from the shoulder like that
people can do it i'm not one of them
yeah it looks good um
dual wield them because why wouldn't you
thanks for watching everybody i hope you
enjoyed that run through
just some of the guns that are available
in hot dogs
horseshoes and hand grenades which i
very much would like to play now
if you'd like to we've got links in the
description to donate
to the royal armouries museum or perhaps
even become a member
otherwise we'll see you next time
[Music]
you